thank you
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everyone
today we have Jason Cheney with us oh
wow
thank you guys so much for having me has
anybody ever cheer for you like that
that's cool
thank you thank you thank you I'm gonna
go to your stand-up show I'm gonna be in
the back with a sword yeah oh no I was
nervous would that improve your set and
your performance knowing he was there
doing that I don't think that does
a jelly almost like heckling but it's on
your side yeah
let's talk about something interesting
all right do you guys have any fears
that you also know are irrational fears
oh
oh man dude you got the heavy ones being
afraid of birds irrational huh is being
afraid of birds irrational or pretty
rational I mean are you just generally
afraid of birds for no reason uh not
Birds specifically but dead birds
oh it's like an omen
like Ravens especially dead Ravens or
like a dead bird that you shouldn't be
seeing like that you know
like what a bald eagle like a parakeet
or like a pair a parrot can constantly
resident dead bald eagle
no yeah like our like a bird that you
don't normally
you know those little birds that that
cats eat like sparrows and stuff like
that's normal to see but if it's like a
like a nice dove that's dead you mean
like a yellow canary because there's
like stuff you're running into nicer dog
no no like no I'm just saying as an
example like if a bird you don't
normally see in the wild is just dead
right in front of you like a peacock
yeah
peacocks are annoying dude I don't know
it just there's a weird feeling well
that's great that is true it's a weird
feeling because I don't know why I'm
afraid of it it's already dead it's not
gonna hurt me but why am I afraid of it
yeah that's exactly you don't want to
touch it I don't want to go near it well
you don't want to touch it anyway you're
just afraid of it yeah I'm literally
just like I feel fear like hanging over
me when I see one interesting and I'm
like why am I afraid of it it's
irrational is it like is it like a goo
like a ghosty thing no I don't think so
it's more it's just a feeling okay it's
just an undeniable feeling it might stem
from this thing that happened to me when
I was a kid so uh my parents or my mom
she bought these two parakeets and uh
she put them in mine in my brother's
room when we were little because we
shared a room and then one day I was
just watching them I think I was like
maybe like four or five maybe six I
don't know and one of them just like
kind of fell over oh and I was like oh
no one of them died for for some reason
I didn't see it die and then I was like
oh that sucks there's only one left and
then one day I was just watching that
bird and it just chirped it went and
then it just fell and I saw that I was
like oh wow uh mom the bird died so she
just maybe you have to not demonic
powers
in the first bite
yeah no I saw it just like
no it was the weirdest thing because
I've never seen any anything just pass
away like that before and I was just
like oh [ __ ] like this bird just died
you know what when I was a kid I saw a
bird die and convulse in front of me I
remember feeling so sad like I cried
it's scary dude because it's like why is
this just flopping around and like yeah
you know and now when I see dead birds
like on the street or like hurt birds
like flapping around it just makes me
feel icky because isn't that Omen though
isn't it like a signify something I
guess I don't know I thought you would
know this dude well I know I know it's
my spiritual guide bro you know
everything experience I always hear
stories about people and Ravens like
especially um like when somebody sees a
raven like they don't normally see him
right and it could just be coincidence
but like when someone sees a raven
something bad happens to them that day
Raven in the in the the black bird like
a black crow yeah similar they're very
simple same family I think they look
almost like dead one of them is Bruce
Lee's kid
um yeah Brandon Brandon Scott Lee about
those birds like when people see them
them they always notice like something
bad happening to them that day it's I
always hear stories about that too like
a black cat yeah but black has less
common but I always hear about it it's
only for white ladies the black cat yeah
like some things are Omens for that
group yeah yeah yeah yeah the number
four for Asians you know for Asians oh
that's interesting what's a bad Omen for
Asians you guys have irrational fears
that are the number based on numerical
things or number four do you have any
three
um based on numbers or anything do you
have any rational views that you're like
I feel like most of my fears are
irrational but I feel like I'm afraid of
everything I'm afraid of a lot of things
you should get the tattoo that matches
with Bart
I fear everyone and everything I do fear
everyone to a certain degree
um oh cheers I do get scared I'm very
jumpy uh but as far as like come back to
me I'm gonna think I'm gonna think of
something good I'm gonna have something
so good I was obsessively afraid of
um
so around third or fourth grade uh me
and my friends did Bloody Mary in the
mirror why are you messing around with
that bro and then at that moment I mean
you know we we grew up super religious
right yeah so I grew up thinking demon
Spirits all those things really [ __ ]
exist right
so at that age I was like well she
didn't come out but she could come out
at any moment now and I just kept
thinking none of the doors open dude now
it's not just a bathroom like that
shit's gonna show up in the middle of
the night that's when my insomnia
started that's when I had to like beg
people to watch me take a [ __ ] what what
because I'm like if I'm in the bathroom
they're good that [ __ ] is gonna [ __ ]
crawl out of the the mirror so I was in
the bathroom and I remember I had like
my cousin by the door like [ __ ]
waiting for me like that like like I had
like um like uh people by the door just
like like holding guard and I'm like are
you still out there it's like yeah I'm
here like wow and then like I would have
like people that I'm like I gotta go to
the bathroom but I'm too [ __ ] scared
you know and I stopped taking showers
because I was so afraid of the bathroom
and this continued probably up until
sixth grade oh until I couldn't take it
anymore a lot of time yeah I mean like
insomnia like all this stuff started
happening because I just I was too
afraid to go to sleep at night so I
would be listening to [ __ ] KISS FM
trying to listen to pop songs all that
and I would like listen to uh Dr Drew
[ __ ] you know like what do you call
it um
yeah like they uh and I would just
listen to radio all [ __ ] night and
not go to sleep and then I'll go to
school the next day because I was afraid
to sleep and I was afraid to like I was
just obsessed I was like that too I
think Asian parents when they believe
all that [ __ ] yeah it really influenced
you so then
when I got
um the internet and when I started to
get this [ __ ] I was like you know what I
all this Spirit [ __ ] is like scaring the
[ __ ] out of me I need to learn like so I
think it was in sixth or seventh grade I
just started researching witchcraft
occult Spirits ghosts I just went
[ __ ] deep that's the way to do it so
I was like it scared me even more to
learn about demons and everything but
after a while for some reason it made me
control the situation better so now
every time I became afraid of something
I would just Deep dive research see how
to take advantage win it whatever and
then so now I think I don't have any
more
um things that are irrational fears
because then I go so deep into it that
that becomes normal and it's no longer
scary I think the fear came from just
not knowing because once you gain the
knowledge and the knowledge is power
right you started to see things from
different actives and that took away the
fear or exposure therapy oh yeah yeah I
think that's what it was yeah doing that
really young and I didn't know like
like what and then like
in like online chat rooms with wiccans
and that dude witchcraft people that
could see ghosts
imagine [ __ ] seventh grade Joe just
chatting on AOL with [ __ ] witches and
[ __ ] like and I'm like when can you see
can you put a good spell on me or like
can I you know like and then like you
just Deep dive into that whole realm and
then after a while you just fatigue you
fatigue from all the spirit [ __ ] yeah
you don't look like you've been exposed
to any wiccans
magic and then after a while you just
realized it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like but they're
made up so I'm a warlock dog yeah they
made up so many things like like
Whispering at night my grandma and mom
said you can't whisper at night or else
the ghost is Gonna Come for real or like
cutting the fingernails using a knife at
night using a knife oh wow I would
always say that to me cutting your hair
yeah what happened to go use a knife at
night I don't know but there's [ __ ] like
blow drying your hair at night you can
only blow dry your hair during the
morning just all these weird now you
gotta let it [ __ ] dry I know a lot of
those are made to help discipline kids
but then I think over time it just stops
making sense no I was like 25 yeah you
know what my mom used to do there was
this little like it was like this weird
little doll that you would keep that we
were all afraid of oh what and it would
she would put it at the top of a
cupboard I don't know why she did this
now I'm thinking about it I was like
it's kind of [ __ ] up with you guys but
like I was so afraid of opening the
cupboard at night that I would just like
walk in the kitchen and it was it was a
cupboard full of Cups but then the doll
was sitting up there and I don't know if
she did it on purpose or she just so you
don't [ __ ] with her nice China but not
even that it was just like regular cups
like so like if you wanted a glass of
water I'd always be like
I grab it and I close it and then I try
not to look so no more great yeah
dude it's true no but it was just like
little things like that I just was
afraid of like ghostly [ __ ] like that
ghostly [ __ ] you know what I mean that's
how I felt about uh in my parents house
it's still there there's this floor lamp
that's just in the middle of the living
room it's just a normal lamp uh it's
about like four and a half feet tall it
just has a regular lampshade as a kid
growing up I was terrified of it for no
reason because it would look like
something no I don't even know why I
would just be like I just feel like it's
[ __ ] looking at me oh this is a
normal lab so I would always like at
night when I had to go get water I'd
always take the farthest route yeah yeah
and then even to this day when I visit
my parents house I'm like oh [ __ ] he's
still there man you ever thought about
throwing that [ __ ] away I knew it was
irrational from day one I knew from yeah
you need exposure therapy I'm age five
that I'm like I'm afraid of this for no
[ __ ] reason it's kind of funny to me
you know but then to this day it's like
it still has a lingering weird take a
picture of that lamp just take the
lampshade off and put it on yourself and
be like
yeah it's a very normal
I think you should trust your instincts
bro trust me you're saying dark about
that lamp
show that lamp a bunch of YouTube videos
of lamps getting destroyed dude
exposure therapy against the lamps just
send a message send a message there's a
little message it might help I don't
know I mean that's as irrational as you
can get and then there's just some
irrational fears like when you're afraid
of certain possibilities or outcomes oh
yeah far from happening yeah but is that
really irrational though because like I
had that I have that with people that
I'm like oh my God you're just gonna
[ __ ] drown because you suck at
swimming so much or like you [ __ ] you
can't I you cannot run so I you're
you're like I know for a fact you can't
run and if we all get chased right now
oh I think about that too like you're
gonna be left behind because your ass is
[ __ ] fat and you're not running like
not about the fat part but like the
conditioning part what are we talking
about no like I I sometimes have random
thoughts like that where we're like I'm
just like if if right now
a warlord comes and bucking points guns
at us yeah you're not going to survive
in this group and you're going to
[ __ ] pull us down yeah I I think like
that but I'm like but I might be in
Waikiki
at the beach and there's no way shaping
for there's no [ __ ] Commando coming
after us right now there's no point but
I'm looking at my friend like you're
gonna get us killed
or we're like be something in you that's
so like innately human that you start to
rape things that way man yeah like we're
swimming and then and then I'm just like
one guy doesn't know how to swim or
whatever I'm all like you're gonna drown
bro like we need to save your ass and
you're gonna kill us because you're an
anchor do you do stuff where you're like
what if we have to swim across that
Island you wouldn't make it yeah yeah
dead weight yeah do you do that yeah I
do that yeah you know what's irrational
about that for me it's like uh I I you
know I'm pretty pacifist I've never
really been in like a fight or crazy
altercation or anything get them Nick
dare you I'm in the same boat I'm gonna
pull guard dude I'm in the same boat I'm
a pacifist but the thing is you know
when you like I think we talked about on
here before you know when you have those
dreams and then you're like no matter
what in your dreams when you're trying
to fight or run away you can't run fast
yeah yeah we can't fight and we
explained that scientific I had to read
this because I was always so what the
[ __ ] right pissed off at myself for
being such a loser in my dreams yeah and
I read it it's like because you're
you're minding your body are literally
not connected when you're in REM sleep
you have deactivated your ability to
move for rest but then if your mind
happens to be conscious of that then
there's this disconnect in your dream
where you're wanting to move but you
can't so it literally connects to that
feeling right like sleep around because
my only uh experience of myself in those
altercations is an inability to move
fast or win
I assume in like regular life those
things can happen because the only
possibility I've ever played out in my
mind was those things because you when
you dream it feels real yeah imagining
it is different right like daydreaming
about like me like also being able to
pull out Bazookas and whoop everybody
like I can do that with my imagination
but the feeling that I've given myself
through dreams has is it feels real so
that's an irrational thing for me
because I'm like wait that you have
dream PTSD a little bit I know people
like that like like I know someone who
um can't drive doesn't have a license
because uh when they were
um what do you call it not astral
projecting
um sleep dream like sleep controlling
like lucid dreaming lucid dreaming yeah
lucid dreaming um they did that for fun
and they got into an accident killed two
people all this stuff so then because of
that
they have this PTSD from the dream and
they can't they freeze behind the wheel
it's like um it's like an automatic
physical thing oh that's weird like they
enjoy driving or like they could play
the game but then they can't
actually drive and pass the test they
[ __ ] up all this stuff yeah oh wow
that's when immersion therapy might help
maybe make them drive a bunch of cars oh
yeah that would be my to be honest
that's my way of helping people is
pushing them there to almost a brink of
death but then because that's probably
the only way to solve it not a good idea
yeah dude I took one of my buddies out
to go swimming
um at the beach right and he's like oh I
don't know how to swim and I'm like nah
don't worry I got a life vest and he
goes I never been inside the beach water
and I'm like just put that on and the
whole time he's trying to like say no
and then like we're all going into the
water right so I throw him in there and
I was like you gotta go straight and he
doesn't know how to paddle or nothing so
I'm grabbing him by his um
uh life mask like this like I'm grabbing
him like that to keep him straight right
and he floats like this and his leg is
like going this way and he's like he's
just petrified like that I'm all like
get your body down he goes how do you
move in here you're talking about David
no no no no
and I I had to hold him and push his
waist down so he's straight and then he
starts going forward and then all this
water is like going in his mouth and
[ __ ] and I had to put him I had to sit
there and keep his body straight like a
baby and then I was like move your legs
and he goes how oh my God and the whole
time we're cracking the [ __ ] up and all
this water splashing his mouth and he's
[ __ ] drinking and he goes this is so
beautiful and fun
well then afterwards like I was just
like all right here take this [ __ ]
floaty and I'm like five minutes your
anxiety is gonna go away eventually like
you'll be okay and then he calmed down
and then I was like he goes I would have
never done that by myself and I'm like
yeah I know but you're like in good
hands we can all swim
Ming yeah I guess the best way to learn
though it is yeah I try to try to do
that with uh like um
last weekend went bungee jumping for the
first time did you really yeah and the
cool thing is that uh so they they give
you the option like you you can either
go backwards where you just look at the
bridge when you jump off or you can just
look forward and just dive and I was
like dude I want to go forward and it's
so like
um like me and my friend were like yo
let's really try to max out on the
feeling of like staring straight at the
ground as you're going oh my God and
just try to really get that glimpse of
actual dying wow you just let go so like
I just go boom and then literally I was
just like all right this is like no
chord like what happened how did it feel
you really do get that like something in
your body's natural order kicks in of
like why are we doing this
and you know obviously you just
shouldn't hesitate because you just
should jump when the guy says jump and
then you will feel that exact thing of
like no we've made a mistake body
why did you do the opposite of what we
need to survive and you really as you're
looking at the [ __ ] Creek at the
bottom and you're just full speed going
it's like time gets really weird because
you start to go through these like
motions of like it starts to feel like
it stops and then you don't know the you
can't make sense of why you did this
interest it's [ __ ] weird yeah if you
do it that way it's probably just
adrenaline rush and it just makes your
brain and the adrenaline and just a
whole like a lot like if you're a
logical thinker that's why it [ __ ] with
you because I like I'm super logical and
then me doing that was like the [ __ ] is
the logic in this so it's a really nice
yeah it's a [ __ ] so if you embrace
the fact that you know but then that's
because like growing up I've always I've
had so many rational fears that over
time I've tried to eliminate them all
and uh so you have exposure therapy too
yeah I love doing that because I think
that is how you deal with for me
personally I don't want to have a weak
mentality so when I notice that I'm
afraid of something I go okay is it
irrational is irrational okay if it's
irrational then either I stop now or I
prove that it's okay yeah and then for
me like I just don't want to get in the
habit of being like no I'm scared of
that so I don't want to do it like
because a lot of the time there's
nothing to be afraid of no I think
everything is you're capable of
unlearning and learning like it's just
repetition yeah so there's no like
identity type I think that's the thing
is people want to identify themselves
with certain labels right like oh I am
afraid of ladders or whatever right so I
don't do it or like oh I had this one
thing that happened to me as a child so
then it's hard or whatever like yeah
there there's a story that makes sense
but you can also work toward rewriting a
new story or like changing how you feel
about it some of it is unnecessary so
you don't need to do the work but
certain things like I'm glad that I did
that for Spirits because if I was always
afraid and I didn't overcome it then I
would probably be defined by that and
then like it would it would ruin me and
I'd be too afraid to take a [ __ ]
shower yeah you know I think some people
really do Relish in those weird things
like it like I've met people that have
strange fears of like uh I don't want to
see somebody chewing food I get [ __ ]
freaked out and it's like you did yeah
and but it's like that's your choice to
live afraid of something like that like
but it's very low but it's like okay uh
I like that you said choice because you
do have a choice to try to overcome your
fear too because I think the motivation
for that is to obtain freedom in some
sort because the fear limits you from
deciding on certain things because
you're like I'm too afraid to do that
but then once you remove the fear you
could pretty much do whatever exactly
yeah see Nina she's very afraid of vomit
and you know she relates it to when she
was growing up she had like an uncle
constantly like drinking stuff and like
throw up so she would always associate
that sound it was something that would
like trigger right so the ironic thing
is like you know like in our
relationship when I would get like
[ __ ] drunk or hungover or something
like that and I would just have those
episodes it would be one of those things
where it's like she just wouldn't even
care to take care of me it's like he's
on his own yeah he can't deal with the
Sight and Sound yeah the ironic thing is
also like she's working like in
Pediatrics with kids all day you know
what I mean and like nice nice dude yeah
high five
but you know what I mean there's also
just that like I want to give her
exposure therapy so that she could take
care of me when I'm hungry no because in
the future run into it you know what I
mean you're always going to run into
that very Human Experience like Dad
reflex or whatever
um so that's why I'm literally just
gonna throw up on her if you need help
I'm gonna do it man we should all do it
throw up near her because we need to
help encourage her anytime you guys see
her next time
foreign